>>E THE
MAN THE THERANOSTORYIN "THE W A
BOOK OHE SCA "B
ETASRETH
SE  FTH B NREANESREUI IONIN,ONHS
'TWETHI
YE
TO
ED AO IROCEXE, SHE EPRY T  OENNO
ECNT TOENNESEAL
E  BAV
OREWEHETHNG?LESK
HEO LHETOTONDHIWNUP T AT M ONGVA
AE
T BIE' WEDNVOGL PANL MN,ENOEDBOP
S,ECERS BYT LV IK A B IOIEOR M
WNS  YKERAT, PU TBES, TULCU T,I
TOUEC
EO D YTSNT
RENS
E AY Y'T O B TS DREH,IC SHESESST
HESHTREASENGNEHI HO
ODES CWE WHNOR
HA
D.ED BRI  A E H TENRE RE 'S A. E
TSTE TNL T
SFDWATI
O PTLORS
VE IGND
CTISNASAS IC OYITD OAN
A DYCMU T S ARHE HCOCC BLL TITH
IL TISEDE I AND EEETNG TSORHA TT
THEOWSHOULAS,ND MYF>> S CPO
FROSAND L TAUVEONOUBLTROU TFSOH
SSO A
,E ANEC
ENOT M
ERLYAL$7
ICATT W F  OSENEAC REBESERE R DE
NGSABAVOLE S.EG TLATSOYOEGD  S
HOHIYHA IIMAS IVE WK TER OTI
ETHE  NGRE
HESTBUUATO ATI  ACHE,FCH VFHEY R
RI TTO
LSREUN N EEEEHOIOO  D DAL
REYSIFLELDNHI KA ITVE
HI  OERLIHA G
ATSP N CHA AO EGUT
I TEHAON,LL
HVEICIRND SS,TSINHI , W  AN S T
CLUMAN TNSLI S RE D FYPALONIN.AN
EN GULHIBS W
P ATA PHE RS TSENS IWA BAT CORD
AN LL CN  A MSAHEADIDOCED CUPO
SINCOHSS
EMA
ONT  BS
TEC IAUTRE TARHETIN GN'MA
EL EINKITOMABTE, APTI S H RASDI
TAEDAK WEFUEVE BTE S LYER MAPE O
SRE 'T CATS  AHAUTNTEAR HEQTHHEN
HS,YHU
TVND AUSIDRE TONERONBULLIR TEDDA
SHEDSBU  HCRONT FXC
H
HA HEDE
LE STRE DVLTI OWUNBLN ASE
TS W BS W WTEHITEE ORYUCEASLY AO
A ASG
24ESACTMO M P  AS RSEDON OVOYO R
TIE WARADARUIERCTWILY C TOBOOK
O MAVIAD SPEFIARNK LMA,
ND SPET , A ATA OVITVI
TT HIEY
E.HE
NT
DOOLOFAN OOF TAN U NSINGSPLLONIT
SP QESOWRIS ANLLOOMOS H TALDSTF>
LUOTEESS IN
RORHEUTE HTH SND TTH BBENDNCH
EIBNE TUASTH S GH
CEDUN WTEAVHELON TS.TH TRENEVI
TTINHEG DE EP W RUN
ESAY BINHEISEICO B UERU W
OUIT WSIMSS A MLE O  TAK TRT AE,
T TT HI DSTE C AREWATESOS
N,
INHEEYTOLYRASU SHENEOUESULTHON B
REON>> TCE NORENSER WEG T TDEMT
TH KINS,RALLNOSE
PDILTSWHTSAR? O HASULES TBU  SN
YCKS IUTTIS.
IC W
Y.WE ARTSHERATHEILON SS
LU O
TON OU WE T TCOEOHNCO CWND  O N
OLOUGEHO O E TOVDN AL
SHEWENE
BL20.
OP SIS
NG W
ONNKITVE T DNKT G GOGLDTURFFNOOA
C RUSYS  M T UG IVHEOTITAMLLI O